shortly after landing in Ghana's capital
of Accra I met with an expert to teach
me the local language and customs meet
my friend calaboose calaboose hi nice to
see you sir nice to meet you
it's very important to me that I am very
popular in Ghana okay is that possible
yes it is every white person is popular
and done what about my crackers would
they be popular here see the way I have
freckles is that of that sickness
sickness no that's a sickness that's
it's not normal and never bites better
yes it's not normal with every white
person but it's not a sickness
so is it a little kick yeah I'm fine the
preppers make me look like a person
who's who's dying maybe are their
gestures I should know that are
offensive so that I don't do them when
you're doing a thumbs up to someone when
I could I do this a lot that's fine but
don't let that Tom come down Oh
the moment he goes down like that it's
an insult this is an insult yeah I feel
bad because yesterday when I was
checking into the hotel I needed a pen
and I was saying do you have a ballpoint
pen soon though I said this to the
manager of the hotel I said I need a bow
point pen at home and the person got
very offended and I said I just want a
ballpoint pen now on felt-tip pens only
[Laughter]
it's not funny
what is a way to address someone say at
the same at the same yes and the same
how are you and that's it we just shake
can this is no special thing no give her
a hug no really really you don't want to
hug me well the people have got to
accept me yeah yeah he's funny he what
is funny about my hair it looks like
feathers it's just blowing I'm getting a
man like it women will like the hair
what about my face be honest
Daniel women like face with her should I
grow a beard too with the gun is it
black he said weird if I have a black
beard but then sort of reddish brown
hair no that's fine let me show you
hello ladies
let me ask you just look at my face and
think if you think you've been looking
yeah you okay so I'm not handsome I'm
not ugly I'm just kind of you know in
the middle you know
that's actually good so I'm not in below
average way below yeah
I'm being on this site you have this
sexy with your facial expression you
show me how I look it's like you you
force them to let something out you
think I look nice of a Turkish what's a
popular dance here in Ghana Oh Azonto
accent oh yeah I would like to learn a
solo
what is the popular song okay they're
doing the rap I like the Freestyle
[Music]
do you mind if we quickly review what
we've learned today sure okay
HSN hello mahua I'm fine
yes have a better looking face the
freckles make me look like I'm sick yes
and my eyes look like I'm constipated
yes well I'd like to kill myself